les invincibles de trappes hante encore
frappé ce samedi 26 mai les trappistes
termine la saison premiers du
championnat et invaincu en emportant un
ultime match en excellence
départementale contre les quais sous
bois sur un nouveau festival offensif le
score 45 à 28
on avait à coeur de finir en beauté
voilà par match est serré à la fin et
de rester invaincu jusqu'à la fin de la
saison on l'avait annoncé on avait envie
de le faire on l'a fait voilà on a fini
le travail
c'est impressionnant c'est un message
fort qu'on en voit notamment aussi après
bon ben c'est un aboutissement aussi
c'est un gros un gros gros travail
l'attrait beaucoup beaucoup travaillé
cette saison
l'année prochaine les joueurs évolueront
en division pré régionale 4 ans
seulement après la renaissance du club
un niveau qui n'effraie pas l'équipe et
on arrive dans les deux premières places
eh ben on comptera en région donc c'est
l'objectif clairement de se garder le
groupe veut renforcer avec un ou deux
membres et puis
et puis d'aller chercher la région sera
parti je pense à des équipes qui ont la
prétention de monter l'année prochaine
on sera pas seul et on sait que ce sera
difficile
on peut pas faire du sport en se disant
on joue à moitié on en a encore voilà
une équipe qui se renforçaient l'année
prochaine et voilà on a envie de
continuer l'aventuré l'objectif c'est de
jouer en région l'amérique longue en
région
la saison reprendra en septembre
prochain l'occasion d'étendre encore un
peu plus cette série d'invincibilité
historique du club
[Applaudissements]